[Applause]
as you can see we've turned our stage
into a bit of a winter wonderland and
that's because i'm sitting down with one
of my dear friends for a holiday
heart-to-heart please welcome six-time
olympic medalist allie raisman
how do the holidays
how do you celebrate them what do they
mean to you ally i love the holidays i
feel very lucky and grateful that i am
close with my family because i recognize
not everyone is close to their family
and
my family and i were celebrating
hanukkah and i celebrated on sunday with
my family and we just kind of all
exchanged gifts and
just had like a really nice day together
and i just love the holidays because
it's a nice time to just take a moment
to reflect on how lucky
i am how lucky my family is and just
spend time together and
my sister's got my puppy milo that i
love he i love him so much and they got
him um some gifts which i
it makes me happy to see him so happy i
was like i don't really i don't want
anything i just if you want to give me
something you can get it all for milo
yeah you because you guys i am obsessed
with you
it's a little unhealthy but i do love
him so much honestly i think that's how
it rolls with dogs i just look at photos
of him when i'm not with him he's so
sweet he's been great for my mental
health too makes me so happy i love
everything you're saying so much
that said
gifts
what are we supposed to do about gifts
ally
i personally
love getting people thoughtful gifts and
things that will improve
people's lives and i i personally love
being very comfortable and cozy so i
have been so lucky i've been working
with arie for um it's been over four
years so i feel so blessed to work with
them and you know every year we we get
together around the holidays and we put
together all these really fun gifts for
friends and family and so i personally
love getting my mom my sisters and my
friends like bathrobes from arie like
very cozy stuff this sweatshirt i'm
wearing these leggings are airy i just
love
getting people cozy things that remind
them to just like
take a bath then put on your cozy
bathrobe or go read a book and just like
let people just chill and unplug because
as we mentioned
life is crazy and it's overwhelming and
so much is going on and so just like i
like giving people gifts that give them
permission to just
relax i love this so much i i actually
am now coveting
everything you're talking about you're
working with arie and the show has
teamed up with them today
and i want you to talk to me about your
partnership with them yeah so i
feel so lucky um i've had the pleasure
of getting to know the arie team so well
and they don't retouch any of their
photos and i've and i
yes
thank you arie thank you thank you thank
you for doing that
working with arie has completely changed
my perspective around
the reason why i have these thoughts of
oh i wish that my pimple was covered up
or i wish i looked skinnier here or
different here is because you've been
like flooded with all these unrealistic
images and i think that what arie is
doing and changing the conversation and
just letting people be the real
them and letting like i just did a
campaign that was about letting their
real voices shine and encouraging people
to just be your real self speak your
truth and be who you are and i think
it's so important for anybody to be able
to walk in a store and to see all these
images of of different people and to not
see any photoshop and just to see the
real them because i think we all
love it
[Applause]
it's really helped me in my own journey
you know coming from a background of
gymnastics where i was in a leotard
every single day there was so much
pressure for me to be skinnier and
skinnier and it felt like it was never
enough and so not only is it amazing to
work with erie because of what they
stand for but it's also just help me on
a personal note because it kind of just
reminds me to focus on what's on the
inside rather than what's on the outside
and i just think if we encourage
companies to keep it real then we all
will feel at ease with keeping it real i
love you for promoting that
that is so fantastic i want to be in
some airy sweatpants like i have a gift
for you here oh you do not i do
are you following me yes i've got some
stuff for you that i've picked out for
you
so maybe we can match
[Applause]
oh my gosh i'm so excited of course yes
i'm not kidding
oh my gosh oh
i've never felt anything to stop it's so
soft oh my god if butter and fabric had
a baby
oh my god ally so you're literally
making my christmas fantastic come true
oh my gosh and do you know what's even
more
do you know what's even more amazing
what is that our studio audience is
going to go home with some airy goodies
as well with a
100 gift card
i'm so excited
[Music]